[Music]
frank's in akron ohio hey frank welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
so i'm a big fan i read the book my
total money makeover i'm going to read
baby steps eventually but i have a
question today because um
i have student loans and i pulled out a
mortgage in 2020
and the student loans keep on getting
deferred and they were supposed to be
due may 1st and then they got deferred
till september 30th
and i really don't know what congress
wants to do with these loans and
i don't really bank on the federal
government but i'm almost like thinking
that this might be one of the things
like forgive one day just to get more
votes so i don't know if i should be
paying those right now because there's
zero interest or
maybe
investing instead
that was kind of my yeah
well um
here's the thing i i've been doing this
a long time
and the number of times i have met
someone who was
uh had their life financially changed
positively
by the people in washington dc
is zero
okay so if you're waiting on your life
to be good because of something that
they do with the island of misfit toys
up there your life's always gonna suck
because you're always waiting you're
always waiting on them to grow a brain
and they don't have them they don't have
a single brain between all of them put
together up there
so um it's not gonna happen
uh listen the democrats ran on the idea
that they were gonna forgive student
loans they're in control the house the
senate and the white house and they've
not presented a single bill
for student loan forgiveness
don't you call bs at this point
i am
and so no they're not going to pay them
off they're not going to forgive them
not anytime soon anyway and you need to
get this stuff out of your life
as soon as you possibly can the tragedy
is is that all these interest payments
have been delayed and then delayed and
then delayed and yet six out of 10
student loans have not made any payments
during this time instead of taking
advantage of the lack of
thrust and crushed it they're sitting
back and waiting on aoc to fix their
life and honey she ain't gonna do it
so no you need to get this paid off as
fast as you can
um anything to add to that i've got i've
got an unpopular take on this um
and it's this
i signed up my wife and i had to pay off
six figures of student loan debt we
signed up for a million
million different loans
but at the end of the day
i looked at somebody and looked them in
the eye and shook their hand and said if
you will help me get through school i'll
pay you back and so i always felt a
moral obligation now i know there's
people who are tricked i know there's
people who are
asked to sign stuff they don't fully
understand absolutely i'm all about
taking care of them but for most of us
we signed our name on the piece of paper
we just didn't do the math we didn't
fully get a have a picture of what we
were going to be asked to do over the
next 20 or 30 years and so i say don't
wait on the government do the right
thing you sign your name pay the stupid
things off and let's get on about your
life yeah while you use all these
interest rate breaks these interests
burn through the way to burn it up and
get rid of it
instead of standing back and waiting on
someone in the white house to fix your
life
never do that on any subject